,
GREG GUTFELD, JESSE WATTERS AND
THIS IS 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY
AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> [BLEEP]!
>> Dana: 12 DAYS OF HORROR IN
UKRAINE AS VLADIMIR PUTIN WITH A
LARGER TRAIL OF DESTRUCTION.
RUSSIA ACCUSED OF WAR CRIMES
AFTER RAINING DOWN ARTILLERY
SHELLS ON CIVILIANS TRYING TO
FLEE TO SAFETY.
AT LEAST EIGHT PEOPLE, INCLUDING
CHILDREN KILLED IN A CITY
OUTSIDE OF KYIV.
UKRAINE SAID RUSSIA IS USING
TACTICS TO PUNISH CITIES AND
MARIUPOL WERE 200,000 CIVILIANS
STRUGGLING TO ESCAPE, THE CITY
HAS BEEN WITHOUT WATER AND POWER
FOR DAY WITH CARNAGE AND
SUFFERING INCREASING, NEARLY
100% OF ITS FORCES STAGED AT THE
BORDER INTO UKRAINE.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, ONCE AGAIN
CRIES OUT TO THE WEST FOR MORE
HELP.
>> THIS IS MURDER, DELIBERATE
MURDER.
THINK OF THE SENSE OF IMPUNITY
OF INVADERS.
THEY ANNOUNCED THEIR PLANS OF
ATROCITIES AND WHY?
BECAUSE THERE IS NO REACTION,
BECAUSE THERE IS SILENCE.
NOT A WORD AS WE DISSOLVED
TONIGHT.
THEY ARE TESTY OF THE AGGRESSOR
TO THE WEST WITH SANCTIONS
AGAINST RUSSIA ARE NOT ENOUGH
APPEARANCE BEFORE LET'S GO TO
BENJAMIN HALL IN THE CAPITAL OF
KYIV MIDNIGHT WHERE YOU ARE,
BENJAMIN.
>> DANA, THE MOMENT IS QUIET AND
KYIV BUT SHOUTING ACROSS LARGE
PARTS OF THE CITY NORTH,
NORTHWEST.
CLEARLY, VLADIMIR PUTIN'S FORCES
MAKING A PUSH FOR THE CITY.
ON ONE HAND TODAY, WE HAVE SEEN
A REAL ESCALATION ON THE ATTACK
OF CIVILIANS.
YOU SEE THE PICTURE FROM
KHARKIV, MARIUPOL AND KHERSON.
ABSOLUTELY FLATTENED AND NO
DOUBT PUTIN IS INDISCRIMINATELY
BOMBING THE CITY'S COMMANDING
SCHOOLS AND HOSPITALS.
ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU HAVE
PUTIN OFFERING HUMANITARIAN
CORRIDORS, POTENTIAL PEACE
TALKS, BUT EVERYONE KNOWS THOSE
ARE AN ABSOLUTE FARCE.
YOU TALK ABOUT HUMANITARIAN
CORRIDORS, AT MARIUPOL WHERE
BUSES ARE TO RESCUE 200,000, THE
BREAD CROSSING THAT OTHER
ATTEMPTS TO GET THEM OUT, SHELLS
TAKING IT IMPOSSIBLE TO EVACUATE
ANYONE.
THEN TODAY, ANOTHER HUMANITARIAN
CAR LEADING TO RUSSIA AND
BELARUS.
AND PEOPLE HEADING RIGHT INTO
THE CAPTIVES HANDS.
SO RIGHT NOW, VLADIMIR PUTIN,
INCREDIBLY LOW BUT THERE WAS A
THIRD ROUND OF NEGOTIATIONS
BETWEEN RUSSIA AND UKRAINIANS IN
BELARUS.
THERE WAS NO OUTCOME
SPECIFICALLY.
THEY DISCUSSED FURTHER
HUMANITARIAN EFFORTS, BUT
NOTHING REALLY CAME OF IT.
SO RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE THIS
SCENARIO WHERE THE ESCALATION IS
ON PUTIN'S SIDE COMMANDING
TOWNS, HITTING VILLAGES AND
PILLAGING VILLAGES.
BUT UKRAINE IS STILL DOING
REMARKABLE HOLDING BACK THE
RUSSIANS.
SO WHAT THE RUSSIANS HAVE
STARTED TO DO, USING LONG-RANGE
WEAPONS.
WE HAVE SEEN LONG-RANGE
ARTILLERY AND THAT IS A LOT LESS
PRECISE PEER THAT IS WHY WE SEE
SO MANY CASUALTIES RISE
DRAMATICALLY.
AND ALSO, SO SUCCESSFUL WITH THE
PLANES COMING IN LOW TO DROP AND
THEY HAVE TO FLY HIGHER.
THAT MEANS FAR LESS ACCURACY.
AND SO A SCORCHED MOVE AT THE
MOMENT THE WAY WE HAD SEEN.
IT IS REALLY WORRISOME WHAT WE
ARE SEEING AND ALL BECAUSE
UKRAINIANS HAVE FOUGHT SO WELL,
PRAY FOR HOLDING THEM BACK.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS RISE IN
INDISCRIMINATE ATTACKS, DANA.
>> Dana: BENJAMIN, STAY SAFE
AND WE WILL SEE YOU ON THE
CHANNEL LATER THIS EVENING.
JUDGE JEANINE, YOU KNOW FOR
THOSE CIVILIANS TRYING TO FLEE
AND TO REALIZE THE ROUTE THEY
WERE TOLD THEY COULD TAKE WAS
VERY HEARTBREAKING.
AN OFFENSIVE, AND YET, HERE THEY
ARE THE UKRAINIANS GO BACK TO
THE TABLE AGAIN TODAY AND
IMAGINE SITTING ACROSS FROM THE
RUSSIANS ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
HUMANITARIAN SERVICE.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE FACT
THAT THEY MIND THOSE EVACUATION
CORRIDORS, THE FACT THEY ARE
SHELLING AND THE CORRIDORS OR
THE CORRIDORS LEAD TO RUSSIA OR
BELARUS IS AN INDICATION THIS
GUY IS NOT AN HONEST ACTOR.
WE HAVE BEEN SITTING YOUR 12
DAYS, OKAY, TALKING ABOUT HIM
MAKE YOU KNOW, ZELENSKYY PUT IT
PERFECTLY.
THIS IS MURDER, DELIBERATE
MURDER WITH IMPUNITY WITH NO
CONSEQUENCE.
HOW IS IT THAT ONE MAN IS
ALLOWED TO UP AND THE WORLD LIKE
THIS?
HOW IS IT THAT HE IS ABLE TO
PUSH EVERYONE'S BUTTONS AND
BASICALLY KILL INDISCRIMINATELY?
SIMPLY TRYING TO GET CANCER
TREATMENT, CHILDREN BEING KILLED
WITH THEIR FAMILIES LEAVING.
I DON'T NEED TO DESCRIBE IT.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS TURN ON
THE TELEVISION WHILE THE WORLD
WATCHES.
YOU KNOW, I UNDERSTAND THE
NO-FLY ZONE, BUT EVEN CANADA HAS
SAID, WE ARE NOT GOING TO ACCEPT
ANY OIL FROM RUSSIA.
NOW, WHAT WE ARE DOING AND I
DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THE
LATEST REPORTS, BUT WE WANT TO
WORK WITH VENEZUELA.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH IRAN.
AREN'T WE GOING TO FUND THE
NUCLEAR BOMBS FOR IRAN?
WHY?
IT'S SO EASY TO MAKE THE LEFT
TURN AND GO TO TEXAS, GO TO
PENNSYLVANIA.
WE COULD BE ENERGY INDEPENDENT
AND YOU REMEMBER LAST WEEK, DANA
I SAID 48% OF AMERICANS ARE
WILLING TO SUFFER AND PAY HIGHER
PRICES?
TODAY IS SATURDAY AND THE 1% TO
SUFFER THE HIGHER PRICES TO HELP
THESE PEOPLE -- 71%.
AND GOOD PEOPLE ACROSS THE WORLD
AND THIS PIG HAS GOT HIS THUMB
ON HER NECK.
>> Dana: JESSE HOW DO YOU
ASSESS THINGS TODAY?
>> IT WAS AWFUL, A BAD WEEK AND
FOR THE UKRAINIANS AND THE
CIVILIANS IN UKRAINE.
I'M NOT SHOCKED ANYMORE.
I THINK IN THE BEGINNING PEOPLE
WERE SHOCKED BY THE HORROR THAT
HE WAS IMPOSING ON THE PEOPLE.
IT IS SHOCKING, BUT WE SHOULDN'T
BE SHOCKED.
THIS GUY IS A BARBARIAN.
IT IS FULLY ON A COURT IS DOING.
AND IT IS GOING TO GET WORSE.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE AN THE
BEGINNING HE THOUGHT THE
SANCTIONS WERE SUPER EFFECTIVE
AND WE'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THAT.
IT WILL GET A LOT WORSE BEFORE
IT GETS BETTER.
AND NOT PREPARE THE COUNTRY FOR
A LONG GAME.
THIS IS A LONG GAME.
OUR AMERICAN STRATEGY, THE
WESTERN STRATEGY IS TO TURN THE
RUSSIAN EMPIRE INTO A GRAVEYARD
IN UKRAINE.
THAT IS GOING TO TAKE A VERY
LONG TIME.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE A LOT OF
DEAD BODIES.
IT IS GOING TO BE SAD.
RIGHT NOW, I'M NOT SURE THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS OR MONTHS, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL VOTE THE
SAME WAY AS THEY DID IN THAT
POLL.
WE ARE IN RECESSION TERRITORY
PRETTY MUCH.
WE ARE ALREADY IN CORRECTION
TERRITORY.
WE CANNOT AFFORD TWODOLLAR OIL
OR $500 OIL.
JOE BIDEN HAS NOT SAID,
DESTRUCTION COSTS ARE GOING UP.
WHAT IS HE DONE ABOUT WHEAT
PRICES OR FOOD PRICES,
FERTILIZER?
THE BLACK SEA IS BASICALLY DONE.
NO SHIPPING COMPANY IS GOING IN
THERE.
NO ONE IS UNDERWRITING ANY SORT
OF TRADE AND THE ENTIRE REGION.
I'M AFRAID THAT YOU ARE GOING TO
HAVE A DOMINO EFFECT THAT WILL
SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL RIGHT OUT
YOU COME OUT OF THE RECESSION.
THIS COMPANY TO MY COUNTRY IS
NOT GOING TO HAVE A RECOVERY IFT
IN THE FACE WITH $500 A GALLON
GASOLINE.
AND THE PEOPLE ARE NOT PREPARED
FOR THIS.
PRESIDENT HAS NOT PREPARE THE
COUNTRY FOR THIS AND WE ARE
HEADED REALLY FAST TO A
POTENTIAL WAR, TALKING ABOUT A
NO-FLY ZONE.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING
TRIGGER-HAPPY.
WE ARE SENDING IN PLANES
POTENTIALLY.
WHAT HAPPENS IF NATO ALLY SINCE
IN A PLANE AND THAT NEEDLEPOINT
FROM A NATO COUNTRY SHOOTS DOWN
A RUSSIAN PLANE?
YOU KNOW RUSSIA WILL BE OKAY
WITH A POLISH PLANE SHOOTING
DEAD RUSSIANS AT THEIR DOORSTEP?
I DON'T THINK JOE BIDEN HAS
WRAPPED HIS HEAD AROUND IT.
BEFORE YES?
>> I DISAGREE WITH A POINT OF
VIEW BUT THE ELEMENTS, THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE A BETTER JOB
OF TRYING TO PREPARE THE COUNTRY
FOR THE CONSEQUENCES.
IN FACT, EVEN IF HE DOESN'T, WE
ARE LIVING THE CONSEQUENCES OF
PAYING MORE FOR CASTLING AND
PAYING MORE FOR FOOD.
I CALL AT THE NEW PPP, PROTECT,
PUNISH, AND POWER BACK.
AUNT WE ARE AT RISK IN UKRAINE,
DEMOCRACY, DECENCY, HUMANITY,
SOVEREIGNTY.
YOU CAN'T LET THIS NATION CROSS
THAT LINE PARTICULARLY IN NATION
WITH THE SOCIOPATHS AND THE
LANGUAGE HE IS TALKING.
WE KEPT TOGETHER NATO.
IT HAS BEEN HARD.
I KNOW THERE IS AN INTEREST ON
SOME TO TRY TO SCORE POLITICAL
POINTS WITH THIS BUT WHEN HUGE
PROBLEMS IN FRONT OF YOU, YOU
HAVE TO SOLVE IT.
IF THAT MEANS BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER BECAUSE YOU DISAGREED
IN THE PATH AND YOU HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO PUNISH THE EIGHT.
HERE IS THE QUESTION HOW WILLING
ARE WE TO SAY $71, 76%, HOW HIGH
WILL THAT NUMBER STAY?
YOU RAISED IT.
IF IS GET TO $10, $12 FROM $11 A
BARREL.
ARE WE WILLING TO BAN THE KINDS
OF FAN SOME ARE PROPOSING ON OIL
AND ENERGY PRODUCTS SIMILAR TO
WHAT CANADA DID?
IF WE DO THAT, SOME CRITICIZED
THE WHITE HOUSE FOR NOT TOUTING
INFLATION.
I WOULD DARE SAY WE DON'T SEE
INFLATION AND FINALLY, WE HAVE
TO POWER BACK.
JUDGE, WHERE I AGREE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY, WE HAVE TO POWER
BACK AND THINK ABOUT WAYS TO
RESTART ENERGY PRODUCTS IN THE
COUNTRY, BE IT KEYSTONE OR LEASE
ON LANCE.
THERE WAS SOME TALK IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ABOUT DOING THAT.
I THINK THEY NEED TO GO FURTHER.
WE HAVE TO BE SERIOUS AND
INTENTIONAL HELPING THE
EUROPEANS.
THE MARSHALL PLANT TO HELP THE
EUROPEANS FIND NEW ENERGY
SOURCES.
NO NATION SHOULD BE DEPENDENT ON
IRAN, VENEZUELA, OR RUSSIA FOR
ENERGY SOURCES.
WE WERE ABLE TO GET OFF MIDDLE
EAST OIL AFTER 9/11.
WE HAVE TO MAKE THAT THE LEGACY
OF THIS EFFORT ONCE WE ARE ABLE
TO GET OUT OF THE EPISODE WE ARE
IN RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: WE WILL TALK ABOUT
ENERGY IN THE NEXT BLOCK BUT YOU
HAVE A GUEST SATURDAY NIGHT.
ANYTHING HE SAID SATURDAY THAT
NOW YOU LOOK TO MONDAY AND SAY,
AHA?
>> Jesse: BOB GATES, DEMOCRAT,
CIA DIRECTOR WORKED FOR THE
PRESIDENT BUT THIS IS HISTORIC
TIMES.
I THINK WHAT HE WAS TRYING TO
SAY, A BAD ACTOR AND NOTHING
THAT WE WILL EVER DO TO CHANGE
THE WAY HE IS.
NOT MUCH DIFFERENT THAN THE GUY
HE DEALT WITH WHEN HE CAME IN
OFF OF PRESIDENT OBAMA AND CAME
IN FOR PRESIDENT BUSH BUT THEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
ALWAYS A HUGE MISTAKE WITH
PRESIDENT OBAMA BLANKETS, MARIES
WHEN HE WENT TO GEORGIA.
OR IS THE THING JESSE IS MUCH AS
I AGREE WITH THE SENTIMENT, WE
ARE NOT LIVING IN A WORLD IN
WHICH WE -- RIGHT NOW WE ARE
DEALING WITH AN ACTOR WITH NO
INTEREST IN TILING BACK OR
COMING BACK.
THIS IS THE MOMENT YOU HAVE TO
STAND OUT AND CHOKE HIM OUT OR
IT WILL GET SO MUCH WORSE IN TWO
YEARS AS HE TAKES MULLED OVER
AND STARTS ON THE BALTIC NATION.
IT WILL NOT BE A GREAT AREA BUT
YES OR NO AREA.
HERE IS WHAT I FOUND, McCRONE
IS ON ANOTHER PLANET.
RUSSIA MUST BE RESPECTED AS A
COUNTRY.
THERE IS NO DURABLE PEACE IF
THEY WERE NOT PART OF THE GREAT
ARCHITECTURAL AT PEACE AND A
COUNTRY BECAUSE HISTORY AND
GEOGRAPHY ARE STUBBORN.
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS THE PROBLEM
AND HE CANNOT BE BROUGHT INTO
THE FAMILY OF NATIONS.
HE HAS TRIED AND LEFT IN HER
FACE.
HE DESTROYED THE COUNTRY,
KILLING CHILDREN DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT IT.
HE HAS PRESS COVERAGE WITH
FLIGHT ATTENDANTS.
WE HAVE TOTAL OIL SANCTIONS AND
COMMENCE THE EUROPEANS TO GET
OFF OIL.
MY GOODNESS, DO WE STAND FOR
ANYTHING?
1-800-VENEZUELA?
IRAN, WE WILL LET YOU FULFILL
WHAT WE USED TO GET FROM RUSSIA
AND NOW WE ACTUALLY GO TO SAY IT
IS ONLY 7% OF THEIR OUTPUT IS
OUR INPUT ON OIL?
SO THAT IS WHY WE SHOULD NOT
WORRY ABOUT STOPPING RUSSIA'S
INPUT OIL FROM COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY?
OF COURSE, WE SHOULD DO.
WE BACKSTOP WITH FRIENDLY
NATIONS.
WE HAVE TO STAND FOR SOMETHING.
WE DON'T HAVE RELATIONS WITH
THEM.
HOW DARE WE CUT A OIL DEAL?
DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THIS DEAL?
IT IS A TRAVESTY.
WE WILL FUEL TERROR AND THE
MIDDLE EAST FOR YEARS.
>> Dana: WE HAVE MORE TO COME